>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED IN
YESTERDAY'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
WISH WE COULD TELL YOU WITH SOME
PRECISION.
THAT'S OUR JOB, BUT WE CAN'T,
BECAUSE IN A NUMBER OF KEY RACES
AROUND THE COUNTRY WE STILL
DON'T HAVE A VOTE TOTAL.
IN ARIZONA, FOR EXAMPLE, THERE'S
NO DECLARED WINNER IN THE SENATE
RACE OR GOVERNOR'S RACE.
AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS LIKE BOTH
KARI LAKE AND BLAKE MASTERS WILL
WIN.
WE'LL SPEAK TO KARI LAKE IN JUST
A MINUTE.
THE OFFICIAL RESULTS MAY NOT BE
IN FOR MORE THAN A MONTH.
A MONTH.
OFFICIALS SAID THEY ARE PREPARED
TO WORK THROUGH THANKSGIVING AND
POSSIBLY CHRISTMAS AS WELL.
THAT MEANS RESULTS BY NEW YEAR'S
IN A RACE THAT WAS HELD IN EARLY
NOVEMBER.
THAT SEEMS LATE HOW LATE IS IT?
BY COMPARISON, THE RESULTS OF
THE 1862 MIDTERM ELECTRICS,
TABULATED BY CANDLELIGHT,
WITHOUT MACHINES OR ELECTRICITY,
IN THE MIDDLE OF A RAGING CIVIL
WAR, WERE CLEAR BEFORE THE END
OF THE WEEK.
THAT WAS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
ARIZONA IS A SINGLE STATE, A
FRACTION OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, WHICH TALLIED ITS VOTES
IN AN ENTIRE DAY.
COUNTING THE VOTES ISN'T AN
ADDED EXTRA YOU GET FOR
GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE A SURPLUS, LIKE
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE,
COUNTING THE VOTES IS A CORE
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT, ALONG
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT, KEEPING
THE BORDER SECURE.
EFFICIENT ELECTIONS ARE THE
REASONS YOU PAY TAXES.
ARIZONA DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
THEM.
WHY IS THAT?
DON'T ASK.
NO UNAUTHORIZED QUESTIONS.
INSTEAD WATCH COUNTRY.
OR IF YOU DON'T HAVE CABLE,
SIMPLY TRUST YOUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS.
>> THAT'S THE WONDER OF
DEMOCRACY, WHETHER YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, AND I
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT TO BE
THE CRANK IN THE ROOM, FOLLOWING
BRIANNA.
STAY OFF SOCIAL MEDIA, PEOPLE.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IF THERE ARE REALLY ISSUES WITH
VOTING, TRUST YOUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS, TRUST US HERE, A NEWS
SOURCE THAT YOU KNOWS, AND
THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOBS AND
DOING IT RIGHT.
>> Tucker: "THEY'RE DOING THEIR
JOBS.
THEY'RE DOING IT RIGHT."
HA-HA-HA!
REALLY?
THE STATE OF OUR ELECTIONS IS
EMBARRASSING, BUT SO WERE LAST
NIGHT'S ELECTIONS.
REPUBLICANS SWORE THEY WERE
GOING TO SWEEP, A RED TSUNAMI.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD US, AND
WE, TO BE HONEST, CAUTIOUSLY
BELIEVED THEM.
THEY DID NOT SWEEP, NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO WEEPING.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY MAY TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE AND SENATE,
BUT ONLY BY A TINY MARGIN AT
BEST.
THAT'S GREAT, BUT THAT WAS NOT
THE PLAN.
THE PLAN WAS SIMPLE.
IT SEEMED EASY A WEEK AGO.
AN UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT, A
FALTERING ECONOMY, AN OPEN
BORDER, THE LOOMING RISK OF
NUCLEAR WAR, HOW ABOUT THAT, PUT
THAT TOGETHER, HOW COULD THAT
NOT BE A MASSIVE REPUBLICAN WIN
NATIONALLY?
THERE WEREN'T.
JOE BIDEN WAS NOT PUNISHED.
IN FACT, HE'S OUT THERE BRAGGING
ABOUT HIMSELF TODAY.
PRETTY FRUSTRATING.
YOU WANT REPUBLICANS TO WIN, NOT
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO GREAT, BUT
.ONE OFFENSE PEOPLE WHOSE JOB IT
WAS TO WIN AND DID NOT WIN
SHOULD GO DO SOMETHING ELSE NOW,
WE'RE SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY OF
THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE.
THEY TOOK HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO PAINT THE MAP RED
AND THEY DIDN'T.
DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE EVIL, THEY
SHOULD BE JAILED.
IT DOES MEAN THEY SHOULDN'T BE
PROMOTED.
NO ONE SHOULD EVER BE REWARDED
FOR FAILURE.
IF THERE'S A TRULY CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLE IN LIFE, IT'S THE
PRINCIPLE OF MERITOCRACY.
YOU REWARD EXCELLENCE.
YOU DO NOT REWARD MEDIOCRITY.
DEMOCRATS KEPT PROMOTING TONY
FAUCI DESPITE HIS INEPTITUDE.
WHAT IS THAT?
THAT'S CORRUPTION.
REPUBLICANS SHOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF VOTING FOR
THEM IF THEY DO?
THEY'RE NO DIFFERENT.
THE QUESTION IS WHY DID
REPUBLICANS UNDERPERFORM LAST
NIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT'S ABOUT
ABORTION, SUBURBAN LADIES MAD
ABOUT ROE, PROBABLY TRUE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, A NUMBER OF
RESOLUTELY PRO-LIFE SURVIVED.
SO ABORTION MAY HAVE BEEN A
FACTOR, BUT IT'S NOT THE WHOLE
ANSWER.
MANY OTHERS ARE SAYING THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS THE REASON WHY
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T DO AS WELL AS
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD.
THAT'S A MORE COMPLICATED
QUESTION.
THE TRUTH IS WE CAN'T SEE THE
ENTIRE PICTURE THIS EARLY.
[COUGHING]
EXCUSE US.
THE TRUTH IS TRUMP HAS BEEN A
MIXED BLESSING POLITICALLY.
THE DOWNSIDES MIXED WITH THE
UPSIDES.
REPUBLICANS LAST NIGHT SUFFERED
A FAIR AMOUNT OF LOSSES IN RACES
THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
TRUMP, IN MICHIGAN, FOR EXAMPLE.
WHETHER YOU LIKE TRUMP OR NOT,
AND MANY DON'T, AND A LOT DO,
IT'S MORE COMPLICATED THAN JUST
HIM.
THEN THERE'S THE MOST AMUSINGLY
STUPID EXPLANATION OF ALL.
[COUGHING]
EXCUSE US.
ALL THIS ELECTION TALK.
SO BAD CANDIDATES WERE THE
PROBLEM.
THAT'S ALL OVER TWITTER.
THE TWITTER PUNDITS ARE SAYING
THE CANDIDATES WERE SUBPAR.
CANDIDATE QUALITY MATTERS.
THAT'S TRUE.
THE QUALITY OF A CANDIDATE DOES
MATTER, BUT HOW MUCH DOES IT
MATTER?
LET'S SEE.
JOE BIDEN GOT ELECTED PRESIDENT
TWO YEARS AGO FROM THE BASEMENT.
JOHN FETTERMAN BECAME A U.S.
SENATOR LAST NIGHT.
DOES ANYBODY THINK JOHN
FETTERMAN WAS A QUALITY
CANDIDATE?
HA-HA-HA.
IS THAT WHY HE WON, BECAUSE THEY
HAD QUALITY CANDIDATES ON THE
LEFT?
DID THE VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA
REALLY WANT A BRAIN-DAMAGED
CANDIDATE?
PROBABLY NOT.
GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR AT LEAST
KNOWING WHO THEY WERE VOTING
FOR.
AND THEY VOTED FOR JOHN
FETTERMAN.
HE WON ANYWAY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT TELLS YOU IN SOME CASES
CANDIDATE QUALITY IS NOT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING.
WHAT IS?
WELL, THE MECHANICS OF AN
ELECTION.
THEY MATTER.
IN THAT CASE, THEY MATTER
SOMETIMES THAN ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUAL RUNNING IN THE
ELECTION.
THE WAY PEOPLE VOTE MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO THE OUTCOME.
SO DOES ACCESS TO COMMUNICATION.
WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
WELL, BECAUSE YOU CAN SAY
WHATEVER YOU WANT, BUT IF NO ONE
HEARS YOU YOU'RE NOT REALLY
SPEAKING.
THAT'S THE CASE FOR REPUBLICANS.
SO OFTEN, REPUBLICANS CAN
COMMUNICATE THEIR MESSAGE
UNENCUMBERED ON A SINGLE CABLE
TELEVISION AND LOW-TRAFFICKED
WEBSITES.
THAT'S IT.
THE REST OF THE AMERICAN MEDIA
AMOUNTS TO A GIGANTIC FILTER
DESIGNED TO DISTORT REPUBLICANS.
IT'S A CAMPAIGN APPARATUS, AND
ONLY THE DEMOCRATS HAVE IT.
YOU CAN WHINE ABOUT THAT.
"OOH, THE MEDIA ARE LIBERAL."
IT'S NOT ABOUT LIBERAL OR
CONSERVATIVE.
IT'S ABOUT WINNING ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS CAN WIN BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THAT.
SO IF REPUBLICANS WANT TO WIN
ELECTIONS TOO THEY MIGHT SPEND
MONEY TO FIX THAT, TO ACHIEVE
PARITY.
AS OF TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS HAVE
FAR MORE CONTROL OVER THE
ELECTION MACHINERY, AND ALMOST
TOTAL CONTROL OF THE MANNER
MEDIA, AND REPUBLICANS DON'T.
THESE ARE NOT IDEOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF WHO'S
RIGHT ON THE ISSUES.
THAT'S SETTLED IN OUR MINDS, BUT
PROBABLY IN THE MINDS OF PEOPLE
WHO VOTE REPUBLICAN IF IT WOULD
KURT TO THEM, BUT IT DOESN'T,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY STAND FOR.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS, AGAIN, NOT
WHO'S RIGHT OR WRONG, BUT WHO
MAKES IT INTO ELECTIVE OFFICE,
WHO YIELDS POWER.
MANY ON THE ROAD DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS AT ALL.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
DETAILS.
2.5 YEARS AGO, REPUBLICAN ALLIES
IN CONGRESS WATCHED IN
GLASSY-EYED SEDATION AS THE
DEMOCRATS REWROTE LAWS AROUND
THE COUNTRY IN ORDER TO GET
THEIR OWN CANDIDATES INTO
OFFICE.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT BY ACCIDENT.
THEY KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
LAST NIGHT, THOSE LAWS, MANY
STILL ON THE BOOKS, PAID OFF.
JOHN FETTERMAN BOMBED IN HIS ONE
PUBLIC DEBATE.
HE HUMILIATED HIMSELF.
HE MADE A MOCKERY OF THE
ELECTION, BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THANKS TO EARLY VOTING, HIS
MARGIN WAS ALREADY IN THE BANK.
NEARLY 70% OF DEMOCRATS HAD
VOTED EARLY IN THE PENNSYLVANIA
RACES.
ONLY 20% OF REPUBLICANS DID.
SO, OKAY, IT'S OVER, BUT IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE REPEATED.
THESE ARE FIXABLE PROBLEMS.
YOU CAN GET YOUR MESSAGE OUT.
YOU CAN FORCE THE OTHER SIDE, IF
YOU TRY HARD ENOUGH, TO AGREE ON
FAIR ELECTION RULES.
BUT YOU CAN'T DO ANY OF THAT
UNLESS YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
PROBLEMS EXIST.
SO THOSE ARE PROBABLY THE REAL
PROBLEMS.
ENOUGH OF THE DEPRESSING RECAP.
THERE WERE BRIGHT SPOTS LAST
NIGHT.
THERE WERE, AS DISPIRITED AS YOU
MAY HAVE BEEN, AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENJOY THEM ALWAYS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE'RE SAVORING.
THE FIRST PIECE OF GOOD NEWS IS
THE FLIP SIDE OF THE WORST PIECE
OF NEWS, WHICH IS THAT JOHN
FETTERMAN WON IN PENNSYLVANIA,
WON WITHOUT SPEAKING A SINGLE
COHERENT SENTENCE FOR THE ENTIRE
CAMPAIGN.
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN APPALLED BY
THAT, BUT IN SOME SENSE IT'S AN
ACHIEVEMENT.
JOHN FETTERMAN IN WINNING
SHATTERED THE THICKEST OF ALL
GLASS CEILINGS, WHICH FOR
CENTURIES AS PREVENTED THE
UNAPOLOGETICALLY BRAIN-DAMAGED
FROM WINNING STATE ELECTION.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOT JUST A
U.S. SENATOR NOW, HE'S A
PIONEER.
THERE'S NOTHING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY LOVES, REVERES AND
ELEVATES MORE QUICKLY THAN A
PIONEER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY.
SO THE QUESTION IS, GIVEN HIS
AWE-INSPIRING ACHIEVEMENT, HOW
CAN JOHN FETTERMAN NOT BE THE
FRONTRUNNER FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION IN 2024?
WE CAN'T CONTROL THAT, HE AND
KAMALA PLAY IT OUT, BUT EXPECT
ENTERTAINMENT VALUE FOR SENATOR
JOHN FETTERMAN.
SAMIER EVERY MOMENT.
SO THE SECOND PIECE OF GOOD NEWS
FOR REPUBLICANS, THAT THEY
SHOULD CELEBRATE, BECAUSE IT'S
GREAT, SOMETIMES WATCHING YOUR
ENEMIES GET VANQUISHED IS A
VIRTUE IN ITSELF, THE SEAN
PATRICK MALONEY LOST.
PROBABLY THE OILIEST, SLIPPIEST,
AND BY AND FAR THE STUPIDEST
MEMBER OF CONGRESS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, LOSING TO
MICHAEL WALLER IN A RACE THAT
NOBODY THOUGHT A REPUBLICAN
COULD EVER WIN.
IT SEEMS LIKE LAWLER WON FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS.
THE FIRST IS THAT SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY SPENT THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF HUFFING AND PUFFING ABOUT
JANUARY 6th.
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN ON
UNLIKE MOST OF THEM, CLEVER AS
HE IS, MALONEY SEEMED TO BELIEVE
IT.
HE CLAIMED THAT AN OFFICER WAS,
QUOTE, KILLED ON JANUARY 6th.
LAST NIGHT AFTER HIS DEFEAT, HE
ONCE AGAIN INVOKED, CAN YOU
GUESS IT, JANUARY 6th.
>> A SHORT WHILE AGO I SPOKE TO
MY OPPONENT, MICHAEL LAWLER, AND
CONGRATULATED HIM ON A GOOD WIN.
WE HOPE THE HIGH WATERMARK OF
SOME OF THE ANGER AND DIVISION
THAT WE HAVE DEALT WITH THIS
ENTIRE CYCLE, FROM JANUARY 6th
ON THROUGH, AND WE HOPE FOR
SOMETHING BETTER FOR OUR
COUNTRY, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT ALL
AMERICANS DESERVE.
>> Tucker: HA-HA-HA.
WE MENTIONED HE WAS CLEVER.
SO WHAT SEEMED LIKE A GRACIOUS
CONCESSION, AND WE'RE ALL IN
NEED OF THOSE ON BOTH SIDES, WAS
IN FACT ANOTHER ATTACK ON
JANUARY 6th, THE INSURRECTION.
WATTS INTERESTING IS THAT
MALONEY'S DISTRICT IS UPSCALE.
IF THERE'S ONE GROUP REPUBLICANS
HAVE HAD TROUBLE WINNING
RECENTLY, SINCE THE INVERSION OF
2016, IT'S UPPER INCOME WHITE
COLLAR VOTERS, BUT IN THAT
DISTRICT THEY WENT REPUBLICAN.
SO REPUBLICANS SHOULD STUDY WHAT
HAPPENED THERE, AND NOT JUST
THERE, ALL OVER NEW YORK.
DEMOCRATS LOST SEVERAL SEATS
ACROSS THE HUDSON VALLEY AND
LONG ISLAND IN BLUE AREAS.
DEMOCRATS, THIS IS THEIR BASE,
UPSCALE SUBURBAN VOTERS,
DEMOCRATS ARE MORE VULNERABLE
THAN THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE.
AGAIN, REPUBLICANS SHOULD STUDY
HOW EXACTLY THAT HAPPENED.
ONE RACE THAT WILL BE STUDIED
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME, AND
ENJOYED FOR AT LEAST SIX YEARS,
IS WHAT HAPPENED IN OHIO LAST
NIGHT.
REPUBLICANS IN OHIO STUNNED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW, THEY'LL TELL YOU, OH, IT
WAS A REPUBLICAN STATE.
BUT EVEN BY THE STANDARDS OF A
SO-CALLED REPUBLICAN STATE,
REPUBLICANS DOMINATED IN OHIO
LAST NIGHT.
NO DEMOCRAT CAME WITHIN 10
POINTS OF ANY REPUBLICAN IN
RACES FOR EXECUTIVE POSITIONS OR
SUPREME COURT RACES.
NOW, IN THE NOW FAMOUS RACE FOR
SENATE IN OHIO, DEMOCRATS SPENT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE
THAN THE WINNER DID.
THAT WOULD BE J.D. VANCE.
BUT J.D. VANCE WON.
NOT ONLY DID HE WIN, HE WON AS A
DECENT PERSON.
THAT'S RARE IN ANY LEGISLATIVE
BODY.
HE WON ON THE RIGHT MESSAGE.
WATCH THIS.
>> NOW THE PEOPLE OF OHIO HAVE
GIVEN US A JOB.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS, OVER THE NEXT
SIX YEARS FOR THE FULL -- THE
FULL LENGTH OF THIS SENATE TERM,
WHOEVER IS IN THE MAJORITY,
WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT LOOKS
LIKE, WE HAVE A VERY SIMPLE JOB
TO DO.
IT'S TO GO TO WORK EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
OHIO.
FIGHT FOR OUR WORKERS.
FIGHT FOR OUR FAMILIES.
FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE STRUGGLING
WITH THE OPIOID ADDICTION
PROBLEM.
FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE, THE
STRUGGLING MOMS STRUGGLING TO
RAISE BABIES JUST LIKE MY MOM
RAISED ME.
WE'VE GOT A GREAT STATE.
WHETHER YOU VOTED FOR ME OR NOT,
THE THING I PROMISE TO DO ITS GO
TO THE UNITED STATES SENATE AND
FIGHT EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OHIO.
THANKS TO YOU WE GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO JUST THAT.
>> Tucker: WE'VE LOST MORE THAN
A HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
FROM DRUG ABUSE IN THE LAST
YEAR.
MANY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
YET WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU
SAW MENTION IT IN A VICTORY
SPEECH?
I WILL FIGHT FOR THEM, THEIR
FAMILIES, THE PEOPLE LEFT BEHIND
FROM THIS EPIDEMIC, FROM CHINA
THROUGH MEXICO, DESTROYING
FUTURE PARTS OF AMERICA.
J.D. VANCE SAID THAT, AND HE
CLEARLY MEANS IT.
HE WON BY A LOT, DESPITE BEING
OUTSPENT BY A LOT.
THAT'S REALLY GOOD NEWS.
ALMOST AS GOOD, WE WILL NOT SEE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME THE LIKES OF
BETO O'ROURKE AND STACEY ABRAMS
AGAINST, BECAUSE THEY LOST YET
AGAIN.
HOW MANY OFFICES HAVE THESE TWO
RUN FOR?
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE DEMOCRATIC
DONORS SPENT TO GET THEM
ELECTED?
HA-HA.
A LOT.
HA-HA-HA.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
AND BOTH ARE UNEMPLOYED, BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH YOU
SPEND ON THE ADVERTISING
CAMPAIGN ON DOG POO P.O.
DOG WON'T IT.
SO NOW THE LAST AND PROBABLY
BIGGEST PIECE OF GOOD NEWS, AS
YOU ALREADY KNOW, IS WHAT
HAPPENED LAST NIGHT IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA.
RON DESANTIS ABSOLUTELY KILLED
IT.
VOTERS OF EVERY EDUCATION LEVEL
SUPPORTED RON DESANTIS OVER
CHARLIE CRIST.
RON DESANTIS EVEN WON AMONG POST
GRADS BY 7%.
REPUBLICANS DO NOT WIN STATEWIDE
AMONG PEOPLE WITH POSTGRADUATE
DEGREES, BUT DESANTIS DID,
WINNING IN ALL BUT FIVE COUNTIES
IN FLORIDA.
TO DEMOCRATS' ASTONISHMENT, HE
EVEN FLIPPED MIAMI-DADE COUNTY.
MIAMI-DADE WENT FOR HILLARY
CLINTON BY 30 POINTS IN 2016.
LISTEN TO THE AUDIBLE GASPS AT
MSNBC AS THEY REALIZED HISPANIC
VOTERS HAD BETRAYED THEM.
>> MIAMI-DADE, A BIG ONE IN
FLORIDA.
WE'VE GOT THE -- YEAH.
SO LET'S PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
MIAMI-DADE COUNTY HAS
2.75 MILLION PEOPLE.
IN 2016, THIS WAS A DEMOCRATIC
COUNTY BY 30 POINTS.
HILLARY CLINTON WON THIS COUNTY
BY 30 POINTS.
MIAMI-DADE IS 70% HISPANIC.
AND LOOK AT THIS.
IN THE MAIL-IN AND EARLY VOTE,
WHICH AGAIN TENDS TO BE MORE
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDLY, MARCO
RUBIO, THE REPUBLICAN IS
OUTRIGHT LEADING IN MIAMI-DADE
COUNTY BY SEVEN POINTS.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
GOOD FOR THEM FOR BEING HONEST
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
REALLY NO LYING ABOUT IT.
AGAIN, IT WASN'T JUST RON
DESANTIS.
IT WAS ALSO MARCO RUBIO.
NO REPUBLICAN HAS WON IN
MIAMI-DADE COUNTY IN 20 YEARS.
BUT RON DESANTIS DID.
MARCO RUBIO DID IT.
IN THE END, DESANTIS WON BY
NEARLY 20 POINTS.
THINGS WERE SO BAD FOR DEMOCRATS
IN FLORIDA THAT CBS WENT LOOKING
FOR CHARLIE CRIST SUPPORTERS,
AND COULDN'T FIND ANY IN PUBLIC.
WATCH.
>> BY THE WAY, I GOT TO POINT
OUT, ONCE WE STARTED DIGESTING
OUR FOOD AND DIGESTING THE DAY,
WE REALIZED ON THAT DAYLONG TRIP
WE SPOKE TO DOZENS OF PEOPLE UP
AND DOWN THE COAST OF FLORIDA,
ALL IN PRECINCTS, BY THE WAY,
THAT VOTED FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
IN 2020, BUT TO OUR SURPRISE WE
DID NOT RUN INTO A SUPPORTER OF
RON DESANTIS' DEMOCRATIC
OPPONENT.
THAT WOULD BE CHARLIE CRIST.
>> Tucker: HA-HA-HA.
POORLY CHARLIE CRIST.
OF COURSE CHARLIE CRIST WAS THE
LAMEST POSSIBLE CANDIDATE THE
DEMOCRATS EVER COULD HAVE RUN,
PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT
DESANTIS WAS GOING TO WIN.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THOSE RARE
ELECTIONS IN WHICH VOTERS WERE,
OF COURSE, REJECTING THE OTHER
SIDE, BUT IN THIS ELECTION A LOT
OF THOSE VOTERS APPEAR, THE
POLLING SHOWS THIS, TO BE
AFFIRMING THE SIDE THEY VOTED
FOR.
THEY WEREN'T JUST VOTING
AGAINST.
THEY WERE VOTING FOR.
THEY WERE VOTING FOR RON
DESANTIS.
PRETTY AMAZING ACTUALLY.
ACCORDING TO DESANTIS, THIS IS A
REALIGNMENT.
HERE HE IS.
>> YOU KNOW OVER THESE PAST FOUR
YEARS, WE'VE SEEN MAJOR
CHALLENGES FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE, FOR THE CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES, AND ABOVE ALL FOR
THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM.
WE SAW FREEDOM AND OUR VERY WAY
OF LIFE, AND SO MANY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY,
WITHER ON THE VINE.
FLORIDA HELD THE LINE.
WE CHOSE FACTS OVER FEAR.
WE CHOSE EDUCATION OVER
INDOCTRINATION.
WE CHOSE LAW AND ORDER OVER
RIOTING AND DISORDER.
THANKS TO THE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT OF THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA, WE NOT ONLY WON
ELECTION, WE HAVE REWRITTEN THE
POLITICAL MAP.
>> Tucker: SO AS DISAPPOINTED AS
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN BY THE RESULTS
LAST NIGHT, WHAT HAPPENED IN
FLORIDA IS LEGITIMATELY A BIG
DEAL.
PROBABLY BE A WHILE BEFORE WE
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT MEANS, BUT
WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT IT WAS
OUT OF THE ORDINARY, UNEXPECTED,
AND PROFOUND.
AS WE TOLD YOU A MINUTE AGO, THE
OTHER THING THAT HAPPENED,
THAT'S KIND OF GREAT, THAT WE'RE
ENJOYING, THE GUY IN CHARGE OF
GETTING DEMOCRATS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS LOST.